j'ai pris des couleurs ou pas une petite
note sur 10 par rapport à avant maman
avant maman alors déjà comment
allez-vous j'ai plus l'habitude de vous
parler là ça fait longtemps de fou ça me
fait bizarre par une caméra il ya une
vidéo chaque semaine pendant le mois
d'août mais moi là j'ai pas tourné
depuis un mois un mois sans lire des
histoires d'horreur comment j'ai bien
dormi à quoi de mieux que de reprendre
le tournage des vidéos avec par ce raid
faux je suis content ça m'a manqué un
vrai aujourd'hui comme d'habitude y aura
trois histoires deux qui sont moyenne
longue et une qui est plutôt courte mais
qui est vraiment incongru j'ai dit
incongrue en vidéo wii en passant par
deux mois là mais j'espère que vous êtes
bien reposé cet été que vous avez bien
qui fait peu importe que vous avez fait
que vous soyez partie ou non vous soyez
sortie ou non que vous ayez joué au jeu
vidéo vous avez fait du sport j'en sais
rien bref j'espère que ça vous a fait
mes gars du bien moi c'est le cas ça m'a
ressources et de malades m'a vraiment
fait du bien désolé je suis dans
l'euphorie je prends des petites
libertés là je parle un peu plus que la
normale au début très d'horreur mais je
suis vraiment content de retourner là ça
me fait plaisir ça m'a manqué bref on
commence avec la première histoire qui
sera l'histoire incongru elle est méga
badens vous allez voir mais la chute est
un peu genre cool je dirais pas que vous
allez taper une barre devant la chute
mais vous allez faire mamie bref cette
première histoire c'est celle de markus
et elle lui est arrivé il ya quelques
années quand il rendait visite à un ami
à lui à cologne et dans la foulée et se
dit qu'il va en profiter pour se joindre
à une réunion de son groupe de l'arpp là
vous vous dites comme moi en lisant
l'histoire mais c'est quoi là je
comprends pas et pourtant vous allez
voir ses proches d'un truc que vous
connaissez sûrement en gros imaginé un
jeu donjons et dragons vous savez où
tout le monde est autour d'une table ans
l'aider il ya un maître du jeu on fait
face à des situations on prend des
décisions etc voilà c'est la même chose
sauf que chaque personne autour de la
table et déguisés et incarne vraiment le
personnage qu'il joue donc je bref vous
l'aurez compris marcus il est fan de rp
et il en fait d'ailleurs depuis qu'il a
14 ans et quand il a commencé à bien
gagner sa vie il a commencé à investir
de l'argent dans ses costumes dans son
rp et ça fait de lui un joueur assez
important de rp il est bon là dedans
c'est son délire bref marcus va donc à
cette soirée rhdp à laquelle il a joué à
ce jeu avec ses amis et puis à la fin de
la soirée il a toujours son déguisement
et à ce moment précis il doit rentrer
chez lui donc traversé la ville en
chevalier médiéval c'est pas un plan de
ouf qu en termes de discrétion t'attire
bien l'attention à une heure où tu as
vraiment envie d'être invisible c'est
chiant il décide donc de se changer
avant de partir de cette soirée pour
redevenir un simple civil dans les rues
de cologne sauf que toute la tenue ne
rendent pas dans son sac il garde donc
sur lui un bouc pantalon un but unique
fin garde quelques trucs qui rend
vraiment pas dans son sac et il se dit
bon ça fera le taf chou globalement
beaucoup plus discret que quand j'avais
la foule tenue de chevalier médiéval
marcus prend le bus le noctilien pour
rentrer chez lui et dans le bus il
remarque un mec qui le être pas mal du
coin de l'oeil mais il se dit bon si les
rôles étaient inversés il ferait la même
île regarderai l'otan se disant mais
qu'est ce que ce mec fou avec des bouts
de tuniques un pantalon déchiré bizarre
qu on est où là quelques années plus
tard marcus descend du bus est cet
inconnu descend à la même station club
markus est bientôt arrivé chez lui enfin
chez lui chez son ami qui l'héberge à
qui il rendait visite à la base en
allant à cologne mais la fin il se dit
que ce serait peut-être cool de taper
son meilleur kebab avec son pote avant
de rentrer dormir il décide donc de
l'appeler et lui demande de le rejoindre
marcus arrive en premier aux kebabs et
il attend et pendant la tente il regarde
au loin et il aperçoit une nouvelle fois
ce fameux mecs qui étaient dans le bus
avec lui et qui cette fois marche tout
droit vers lui mais marcus il se dit bon
bah le mec rentrer chez lui il vient
vers moi mais en même temps je suis dos
à une rue donc j'ai juste mot décalé
contre le mur et puis va rentrer chez
lui vaut la f1 de l'histoire sauf qu'au
moment où il se décale l'inconnu lui
attrape le bras il sort un couteau il
lui dira le regardant dans les yeux je
veux ton portefeuille ton sac et on
téléphone
marcus sous la menace du couteau lui
donnent son portefeuille et son
téléphone mais il lui explique que dans
son sac y'a rien à part un costume de rp
qui lui a pris des années à faire et qui
vaut que dal sauf que cette simple
phrase déclenché chez cet inconnu on ne
sait quoi et marcus se prendre deux
coups de couteau en plein dans le ventre
hélas les souvenirs de marcus sont fous
et souvient de se faire secouer presque
immédiatement après tomber par terre par
quelqu'un est ce quelqu'un c'est son ami
qui en fait vient de le rejoindre et
vient de le voir se faire poignarder
sous ses yeux mais à ce moment-là
l'inconnu il n'a pas encore pris la
fuite il est avec les affaires de marcus
à seulement un mètre de marcus et il se
met à marcher vers la mine marcus pour
probablement l'agressé lui aussi la mine
marcus regarde tout autour de lui et il
tombe sur le casque d'armures médiévales
de marcus qui est tombé du sac quand le
mec le lui a arraché des mains la mine
marcus prend donc ce casque dans la main
il m'aidait énorme coup sur le mec avec
et ça suffit à le faire fuir à ce
moment-là marcus est toujours à terre il
est mal mais l'inconnue n'est plus là il
ya plus de dangers et donc son ami le
relève et commence à examiner ses
blessures et là c'est le fameux truc
incongru dont je vous parlais la tunique
de marcus et déchiré mais il se trouve
que par chance il avait gardé sous sa
tunique sa [ __ ] de côte de maille
c'est lourd ça ce compact pas ça se plie
pas cernant faire du coup il a gardé sur
lui avant de partir et c'est ce qui lui
a sauvé la vie ce jour là puisque au
lieu d'avoir une énorme plaie profonde
au niveau de l'estomac il a juste
quelques égratignures
et un énorme bleus mart us explique donc
que si ce soir-là il revenait d'une
autre soirée qu'une soirée roleplay à
laquelle il était habillé en chevalier
médiéval il serait mort pour avoir voulu
dire aux gars que ça servait à rien de
volé son sac qui contenait des costumes
en mousse c'est incroyable la chance
qu'il a eue voilà c'était le petit truc
incongru dont je voulais vous parler en
premier ça nous fait extrêmement bas des
mais ça finit bien le hasard est un peu
improbable bref je vais faire du rp moi
c'est sûr messieurs dames il est temps
de passer à la deuxième histoire et
alors là accrochez-vous je crois qu'on
n'a pas encore eu ce cas de figure là
c'est l'histoire de zoé et c'est une
histoire qui a été postée sur le let's
not mythe fr et elle est incroyable
merci zoé d'art pris tant de la raconter
tout d'abord contexte zoé à 20 ans elle
habite en banlieue dans une petite
résidence de six maisons qui sont unis
par une petite cour cette petite cour
est censé être protégé par un portail
sauf qu'il est extrêmement souvent cassé
et ce jour-là devinez quoi il l'était
c'est à dire qu'il a pas besoin de la
clé du portail pour pouvoir l'ouvrir
puisqu'il était juste grand ouvert la
maison de zoé sa rez-de-chaussée et un
étage à l'étagé à 4 chambres dont la
chambre de zoé et au rez de chaussée il
ya une chambre d'amis transformées en
chambres de soins pourquoi en chambre de
soins puisque zoo explique qu'elle a des
gros problèmes de santé et que depuis
toujours elle reçoit la visite
d'infirmières dans une pièce dédiée à sa
dans laquelle est rangé donc tout le
matériel dont les infirmières ont besoin
les médicaments bref c'est là où se
déroulent les soins dont zoé a besoin
dans cette maison se trouve aussi le
chien de zoé dont elle est très proche
tellement proches qu'il est capable de
sentir quand zoé va faire une crise
d'épilepsie avant qu'elle la fasse
évidemment il aboie jamais même pas sur
les infirmières qui passe à la maison
puisqu'il est habitué à leur passage et
il les connaît tout enfin la fréquence
des passages de ces infirmières ces
quatre à cinq fois par jour c'est
conséquent mais c'est le traitement de
zoé vous comprenez donc pourquoi une
pièce dédiée à ça bref ce matin-là il
est 8 heures et comme chaque matin
sandra l'infirmière libérale parmi
d'autres qui s'occupent de zoé toque à
la porte zoé lui ouvre la porte elles
vont toutes les deux dans la chambre de
soins pour que sandra s'occupe d'elle le
traitement c'est un process assez précis
auquel zoé est complètement habituel le
connaît par coeur d'abord à lui fait une
perfusion d'anti douleurs ensuite elle
remplace ces diffuseurs d'antibiotiques
qu elle lui fait une prise de sang puis
enfin elle remplace la cassette de sa
pompe à morphine pendant tout ça
évidemment ol discute avec l'infirmière
en l'occurrence sandra elle parle un peu
de tout et de rien après 40 minutes de
soins sandra donc s'apprête à partir de
chez zoé et elle lui dit bon ben voila
je reviens dans quatre heures mais
aujourd'hui j'aurais peut-être un poil
de retard ça n'a l'air absolument pas où
et qui lui dit ok pas de souci et qui va
ensuite se poser dans son canapé avec
son chien le temps passe et plus elle
entonne voiture se garer devant chez
elle elle regarde l'heure et il est 11
heures 50 on est donc une heure avant
l'arrivée prévue de cendres et puis en
levant les yeux elle voit que son chien
est maintenant assis devant la porte
d'entrée et qui grognent mais malgré
tout the way elle n'ait pas paniquer du
tout pourquoi parce que c'est un truc
qui lui est déjà arrivé qu'une
infirmière arrive une heure en avance
puisque dès fois l inverse deux créneaux
pour des histoires de logistique c'est
plus pratique selon où elles sont et
c'est elle entend toquer à la porte et
ça c'est étrange parce qu'habituellement
à partir du deuxième chrono de la
journée l'infirmière ne prend plus le
temps de toqués elle rentre directement
elle va voir zoé et puis en ouvrant la
porte elle tombe non pas sur sandra mais
sur une infirmière qu'elle n'a jamais vu
elle lui explique qu'elle s'appelle
camille qu'elle est étudiante en 3e
année d'infirmières et que sandra sera
un peu en retard et elle lui a donc
demandé de venir préparer les soins
avant son arrivée encore une fois c'est
un truc est déjà arrivé pas mal de fois
à zoé ça mais bon quand même elle
étonnée que sandra les pas prévenu
surtout qu habituellement au moindre
imprévu elle reçoit un message direct
elle se dit qu'elle doit être débordées
et donc elle montera camille cette
étudiante la salle de soins mais son
chien continue de grenier à tel point
que zoé le sort de la salle de soins et
l'enferment dans le salon du retour dans
la salle de soins zoé ça soit elle sort
son tel el cheikh des trucs le temps que
camille face toutes les préparations et
en levant les yeux doux et voit que
camille a dans la main une seringue
alors pour vous et moi oui y'a rien
d'anormal mais pas posée l'ol connaît
par coeur le process de ses soins il
commence systématiquement par
l'ouverture d'une seringue 9 pré remplie
de sérum physiologique à l'aide de
laquelle l'infirmière reims son cathéter
centrale là la seringue que camilla dans
la main c'est pas une seringue qui vient
d'être des balles et c'est une seringue
dans laquelle elle vient de mettre
quelque chose camille en tournant la
tête elle voit les ampoules qu'on
utilise pour lui injecter son traitement
et ses ampoules ne sont pas ouvertes
camille s'approche d'elle pour lui
injecter le contenu de la seringue et au
même moment zoé reçoit un message de
sandra un message dans lequel elle lui
dit qu'elle arrive dans 5 minutes et
dans lequel et lui demande de sortir les
affaires pour qu'elle gagne du temps
chaud et comprend immédiatement ce qui
se passe pourquoi sandra lui demanderait
de sortir des affaires après avoir
envoyé une apprentie infirmières le
faire pour elle ça n'a aucun sens la
personne dans sa salle de soins n'a en
aucun cas été envoyé par sandra ou une
autre infirmière zoé se lève elle
regarde camille dans les yeux et lui dit
je doit urgemment aller aux toilettes
j'arrive elle ouvre la porte du salon
pour son chien puisse la rejoindre et
elle va s'enfermer dans les toilettes
avec son chien quelques secondes plus
tard elle entend sa porte d'entrée
claqué et puis le silence plus un bruit
dans la maison et quelques minutes plus
tard elle entend une nouvelle fois sa
porte d'entrée claque puis elle entend
sandra qu'il appelle au loin en lui
demandant si tout va bien zoé elle est
soulagée elle sort des toilettes elle
sandra et lui explique ce qui vient de
se passer et elle est complètement
choqué sandra prend tout de suite très
au sérieux la situation elle appelle la
police ils fouillent la salle des soins
ils essaient de trouver des indices tête
des cheveux de cette personne ils font
des prélèvements et surtout il récupère
la seringue que camille n'a pas emporté
avec elle quelques jours après cette
histoire zoé a eu des nouvelles d
analyse du contenu de cette soirée et
comme prévu c'était pas du tout du sérum
physiologique dans cette seringue y
avait deux trucs le premier c'est un
paralysant y avait une dose assez
puissante pour paralyser un homme de 120
kg le deuxième c'était un médicament
pour diminuer le rythme cardiaque sauf
que la dose de ce truc là dans la
seringue était tellement énorme qu'elle
aurait arrêté le coeur de n'importe qui
mais une semaine plus tard zoé a de
nouveau des news apparemment cette fille
camille la suivait depuis au moins trois
mois c'est à dire que la police a réussi
à trouver des images de caméras de
surveillance d'une pharmacie et on y
voit zoé au comptoir et camille le rayon
d'à côté très attentive sur ce que zohra
comptes aux pharmaciens c'est donc en
laisse purement comme ça qu'elle aurait
su que l à des traitements à domicile
qu'elle aurait su les heures de passage
approximatif des infirmières qu'elle
aurait cieux si son adresse alors tout
ça s'est pas fait en une seule fois ça
s'est fait sur plein de jour comment se
termine l'histoire vécue telle enquête
est toujours en cours zoé ne sait
toujours pas qui était camille et
pourquoi elle l'a choisie elle est
pourquoi elle voulait arrêter son coeur
tout ça pas trop de sens c'est une
tentative de meurtre quoi gratos zoé a
pas déménager l'habite toujours au même
endroit simplement c'est
systématiquement les mêmes infirmières
manants qui passe la voir et aussi
maintenant quand elle se rend dans une
pharmacie pour acheter ces traitements à
chaque fois c'est une forme assez
différentes un jour différent et une
heure différente voilà horrible cette
histoire ah je retiens mon casque j'ai
chaud bref j'espère qu'elle vous a fait
kiffer celle là moi je la trouve un
croissant de cazaux et a été dense tu
regarde cette vidéo victimes françaises
et a été d'un courage incroyable merci
de nous avoir partager ton histoire et
puis courage pour des traitements
messieurs dames c'est l'heure de la
dernière histoire et c'est celle d'eva
l'histoire se passe un an avant qui va
là raconte à une époque où eva vit seul
entre-temps elle a emménagé avec son
copain félicitations et bas ce jour-là
il est 20 heures elle est tranquille
dans sa chambre à l'étagé de sa maison
elle bosse sur un projet de broderie et
eva qu elle fait un truc elle est
vraiment focus donc elle a aucune
conscience de ce qui se passe autour
d'elle quoi bref elle est donc en train
de broder et puis d'un coup elle sans
son lit vibrer rassurez vous rien de
paranormal c'est juste que sa chambre et
au dessus de la porte d'entrée de la
maison et donc à chaque fois que
quelqu'un ferme cette porte d'entrée ça
fait vibrer le cadre du lit des 20 alors
salle alain pas du tout pourquoi parce
que même si elle vit seule son copain
vient très fréquemment l'avoir chez elle
et quand il vient la voir il fait un peu
comme s'ils vivaient ensemble c'est à
dire qu'il tokpa y sommes pas là
prévient pas y rentrent ils ferment la
porte ils se posent dans le salon et il
attend qu eva décent pour le voir bref
ce jour là eva est vraiment plongés dans
sa broderie et lui faut cinq bonnes
minutes avant de descendre au
rez-de-chaussée dire bonjour à son
compagnon elle sort donc de sa chambre
elle est en haut des escaliers et en
regardant au rez-de-chaussée elle voit
que sur le porte-manteau n'y a pas la
veste de son mec pourtant
systématiquement quand son mec bien chez
elle il retire sa veste et ses pompes
immédiatement elle comprend qu'elle a dû
rêver elle retourne dans sa chambre pour
continuer sa broderie au moment de
remettre ces reports elle entend un
énorme bruit venir du rez de chaussée
immédiatement elle va panique elle
retourne à l'entrée de sa chambre et
elles crient le nom de son petit ami
pour savoir si tout va bien
malheureusement aucune réponse ou plutôt
par la réponse espérée ce qu'elle entend
en retour c'est des bruits de pas se
diriger vers sa porte d'entrée qui fait
face aux escaliers elle a donc tout de
suite un très mauvais pressentiment elle
retourne très discrètement mais très
rapidement dans sa chambre prendre son
portable et puis elle va s'enfermer dans
sa salle de bains à l'étagé aussitôt eva
appelle la police elle est sur le point
de leur donner son adresse lorsqu'elle
entend des pas dans ses escaliers la
personne au téléphone lui demande son
adresse et ce qui se passe et eva en
chuchotant lui donne juste son adresse à
répétition sans rien expliquer elle n'a
pas le temps et à quelqu'un qui est en
train de monter les marches et quelques
secondes plus tard ce quelqu'un est déjà
devant sa chambre là où elle est et ya à
peine vingt secondes eva elle en est
maintenant certaine ce n'est pas son mec
qui est dans la maison clairement pas et
elle décide d'ouvrir la fenêtre de la
salle de bains et de descendre sur le
toit de son garage elle est donc sur le
toit de son garage et là il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que de ressaut t sauf
que cette fois c'est un peu plus on
health explose les genoux à l'arrivée
elle sera complètement et là elle se
relève elle n'a pas le temps de réaliser
ce qui vient de se passer quelque court
le plus vite possible le plus loin
possible il faut savoir qu'à ce moment
là on est mi octobre il fait
complètement noir dans la rue elle sait
pas où elle va elle sait pas si le mec
la suit ou pas a lancé rien juste elle
court et pendant sa course elle fait un
truc assez ouf elle prend son téléphone
elle raccroche avec la police alors
qu'elle sait toujours pas s'ils vont
venir ou non et elle appelle son petit
ami pour lui expliquer ce qui vient de
se passer dans sa course elle se réfugie
dans un magasin dont elle donne
l'adresse à son copain au téléphone à
son arrivée et lui explique donc ce qui
vient de se passer il est complètement
choqué il décide de rappeler la police
parce que là ils peuvent pas rentrer et
le mcee peut-être toujours là il est
peut-être très dangereux et c'est
seulement 15 minutes plus tard quinze
longues minutes plus tard qu'une
patrouille arrive à la maison autant
vous dire que ces 15 minutes silva était
resté dans la salle de bain ça l'aurait
pas fait cinq minutes après leur arrivée
la police rappelle le mec d'eva pour lui
expliquer un peu ce qu'ils ont découvert
dans la maison déjà en arrivant la porte
d'entrée était grande ouverte et dans le
salon la grande table basse avait été
complètement renversées c'était ça le
fameux bruit qu'ils avaient entendu
quand elle était à l étage à laitages la
porte de la salle de bains elle a été
enfoncée tellement fort que le cadre de
la porte lui même s'est barré du truc en
revanche la maison n'a pas été fouillé
et rien n'a été volé après avoir eu ses
explications et vas y sont mais combien
sur pu retourner à leur maison avec les
policiers toujours présents sur place
évidemment une équipe d'ambulances a été
appelé eva s'est fait examiner elle
s'est fait un peu soigner ses genoux
compris cher dans sa chute et va
réaliser que bah c'était peut-être très
dangereux de laisser ouvert sa porte
pour que son mec puisse la rejoindre
quand il veut et que peut-être il aurait
fallu la fermer à clé constamment et lui
donner un double des clés mais d'un
autre côté elle vit dans une toute
petite ville dans laquelle il se passe
vraiment rien et des trucs comme ça
s'était jamais arrivé les deux semaines
qui suivent évidemment le mec d'eva a
littéralement habité chez elle normal et
ils ont eu des news ils ont eu le fin
mot de l'histoire la police a pu checker
toutes les caméras de surveillance du
quartier et sur ses caméras de
surveillance on voit un mec essayer de
rentrer dans deux maisons avant de
rentrer dans celle des vins parce
qu'elle n'avait pas verrouillé la porte
puisque elle savait que son mec allait
venir dans pas longtemps de plus sur les
caméras de surveillance on voit qui est
ce mec et ce mec c'est un voisin des
vins un voisin qu'elle a croisé quelques
fois qu avait l'air parfaitement normal
hormis le fait que à chaque fois lui
demander des news sur son taff et sur
son mec alors elle a jamais su pourquoi
son voisin était rentrée chez elle par
effraction et ce qu'ils voulaient en
tout cas le mec a été arrêté et placé en
détention puis d'être jugé et elle a
aussi entre temps emménager avec son mec
voilà si j'étais voisin qui regarde
cette vidéo les gars je ferme tout le
temps ma porte d'entrée ok d'essayer
même pas devenir aller direct ailleurs
ok bref c'est la fin de ce serait de
voir l'histoire vous ont-elles plus est
elles ont après bon clément à tout
raccourci tout mais c'était quand même
long je crois aujourd'hui j'espère
qu'elle vous ont plu je suis content
d'avoir ton et serait de 1 j'ai un peu
galéré des fois à dire certaines phrases
et où je sens que je suis rouille et là
il faut que je reprenne du poil de la
bête comme on dit bref on se revoit très
bientôt du coup pour de nouvelles vidéos
là on va repasser à une vidéo tous les
cinq six jours encore une fois ne
devenez pas parano à cause des serait
d'horreur juste rester vigilant surtout
avec les inconnus on est vigilant
vérifiez vous avez bien fermée à clé la
porte d'entrée que vous avez bien la
cote de maille qui est mise au cas où
quelqu'un vienne la nuit pour ça y est
enfin j'étais plus du tout par addoha
pendant mes deux dernières semaines de
vacances j'avais oublié là le fait de re
lire des trucs comme ça ça là me je suis
allé les cerises hausse à très vite
[Musique]